hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game this one is from
round three of the norway chess 2022.
it's from the classical section and it's
magnus carlsen versus temurajabov uh two
of them have played quite a lot of games
together so far their head-to-head
result is nine wins for magnus and two
wins for uh for timmer with 21 draws so
very very exciting stuff as they've
played so many classical games together
uh but this one is uh well it's pretty
standard what you would expect uh from
uh from a game uh where rajaw is playing
with the black pieces you know that he
always plays very active chess he
sometimes gives up a little bit of
material sometimes a lot of material
but the games are always very exciting
and this um is no exception so let's
check it out uh magnus with the white
pieces opens with d4 and we're going to
have a very nice catalan so our java
goes knight to f6 we have c for e6
knight to f3 and d5 the queen's gambit
decline is on the board and now g3
magnus opts for the
catalan opening with bishop to e7 and
bishop to g2 now uh the closed catalan
we have castle's castles uh and now d
captures on c4 proceeding in the
classical line queen to c2 ready to uh
uh
pick pick up the pawn uh
on c4 that's doubled and now usually a6
is played here but her job goes for b5
he defends the pawn which is not that
common but it's um
uh it's also a very much playable now
the thing is yes you open up this
diagonal but you don't really have any
good jumps with the knight if knights to
e5 we're just going to play knight to d5
which is kind of the square that this
knight really needs to go to uh
so so there's that then for example if
e4 if you want to grab the full center
chase away tonight you will run into
trouble after knight to b4 so now it's
just a very very good position for black
so instead after b5 the magnus
challenges the structure with a4 right
away this is how this is played bishop
to b7 we have a captures on b5 and now
uh arajava makes it very interesting by
playing a6 and okay b captures an a6
knight captures and now queen captures
on c4 again this has all been played
before
bishop to d5 attacking magnus's queen
here and now uh the popular retreat
squares are c3 and d3 magnus chooses the
c3 square and now we have pawn to c5 you
do not want to have this backwards pawn
all the way on c7 so c5 you want to
trade it off uh and now
all the games that reach this position
bishop to e3 is the mood that was played
in them uh one of the more notable ones
wesley so has defeated the ani pognishi
in this exact same position with bishop
to e3 but here magnus plays bishop to f4
it's a new move uh so already as of move
13 we have a completely new game
now rajavo goes for uh knight to e4 he
challenges the queen and usually uh with
the bishop on e3 the queen is retreated
to e1 after this attack from the knight
but here magnus plays queen to c1 so
already it's quite a different position
than uh maybe what uh what rajab had in
mind so here c captures on d4 you want
to trade this there's no reason not to
knight captures and now comes knight e
to c5 and here uh magnus already
confuses uh uh tamer a little bit uh
knight the b4 is uh uh much much much
better yeah because you want to uh trade
down uh
not too too many pieces here okay you
could trade rooks but let's say knight
to c3 now you you defend your rook with
the queen and now we can trade
everything like this for example knight
captures b captures we're going to play
bishop captures and g2 king captures now
knight back to d5 we attacked the pawn
and the bishop and you could go back
with bishop to d2 but you could also
just trade for example captures captures
we push e4 knight captures queen
captures and we get this position where
it's uh rajab of the bishop against
tonight and magnus has a past c pawn but
um it shouldn't uh
be possible uh to to win this with white
however it it is magnus who is up a pawn
and it can only be white who's ever
better here
uh so maybe that's that's the way to go
but okay knight e the c5 was played and
now magnus just captures on d5 you'll
see the difference bishop captures we
have queen captures on d5 and now bishop
back to e3 just defending his knight and
now you're constantly uh
gonna have to be careful about this push
pawn to b4 for the moment it's not
possible but you can see how that
position was uh a bit easier for black
to play than this one so he goes queen
back to b7 controls the b file now comes
knight to d2 and now rook ate the c8 you
don't want to play rook f to c8 because
that kind of
makes it problematic to you for you to
move your pieces if you move the knight
magnets will very happily just trade uh
so instead uh rojava brings this rook to
c8 and now we have queen to b1 getting
the queen away from the c file and also
b4 will come at some point so knights to
b4 uh and now knight four back to f3 uh
we have queen to b5 going after the e2
pawn and magnus just calmly defends it
with rook to e1 we have rook f2d8
finally bringing that rook into the game
and now king to f1 we defend the e2 pawn
and now our rook can also get into the
game h6 rajab will make some reading
room for the king here and rook to c1 so
magnus still up upon he's getting uh his
pieces into the game because arjaba was
way ahead in development now magnus is
catching up a bit uh but still no actual
clear way how to push that pawn bishop
to f8
and now knight to e4 and now magnus uh
offers a nitrate and it's pretty uh
impossible to to prevent this you are
attacking the c5 square three times so
knight to b3 this is how ojava decides
to trade this and now both of the rooks
are attacked so you have to play rook
captures on c8 this is the only move for
magnus rook captures and now knight to
c3 here your rook is uh hanging but
if you just do something about that
and there's not all that much you can do
then this rook is coming to
the c2 which will be a pretty pretty big
problem so here the way to deal with
this is knight to c3 we attack the queen
first and only after the queen moves now
we move the rook rook to a4 as now the
knight also defends the a4 square so
it's um uh
not as possible for a java to
make some sort of a tricky move and here
we have knight to d5 and knight to d5 is
very interesting but we also need to
discuss bishop to c5 as this is much
safer and again it allows our job to
just um
grab hold of the position because now
for example queen e4 we we defend our
bishop here
now comes knight to d5 now we're just
threatening to pick up the bishop and
there's no good way to deal with this
because if you capture the bishop then
we're just going to play knight captures
and c5 attack the queen and the rook
here so what you will do probably is
just move the move the rook rook to c4
and now we're gonna play knight captures
on e3 with check mess up uh white's pawn
structure and then just continue the
game okay we don't want to trade queens
we're gonna play queen to a6 and now
magnus is still up upon but we've ruined
his king side we're going to be able to
attack the white king a little bit
easier and well even if it if everything
just disappears from the board
it's it's a double e pawn so it's not as
clean as being up a pawn but here after
knights to d5 it's a little bit
different because now magnus just trades
on the five queen capture knight
captures queen captures and now plays
king to g2 and again it's classical so
we need to discuss some really awesome
lines uh queen to d3 just offering a
queen trade seems like it's not enough
yes you are up upon but it shouldn't be
enough however here uh it becomes very
interesting after captures captures
there is no clear good move for black
because the move that comes to mind is
of course rook to c2 and now okay once
you have the rook on the seventh or on
the second uh it's uh you know uh you
you just don't care of being down down
upon uh but here rook a8 and uh white
just wins that's the problem uh there's
no good way to defend and even okay you
can capture yes you are controlling c5
so white doesn't have bishop c5 there's
knight e5 we're just gonna play knight
d7 win the bishop and that's it there's
no way to defend this so uh you can't
really play this rook the seat you move
and without this active rook the c2 move
uh it's not easy to
find the move uh some f6 g5 ideas maybe
but uh it's it's hard to say uh so
instead okay magnus played king to g2
and now queen back to c6 now our java
with full control of the c file and the
knight on b3 prevents that pawn uh from
ever moving forward but here we have
rook to a7 by magnus uh and now arajabo
needs to find the move and he plays g5
and this is in fact a very good move
it's a top move recommended by the
engine the problem is
uh this is only move 30. magnus has 40
minutes on the clock radio has three and
a half minutes on the clock so he still
needs to make 10 more moves to reach
time control and magnus plays queen to
d3 just a nice move activating the queen
now comes knight to c5 attacking the
queen now comes queen c4 and the queen
to b6 unpainting from the c file and
also attacking the rook here now comes
the b2 pawn is also attacked so queen a2
defending b to end the rook here and now
queen back to c6 so rojo survived all of
this but now it's just possible to push
the b pawn and this is exactly what
magnus does we have pawn to b4 and the
position is now incredibly difficult to
defend the only move that allows rajab
to stay in the game is knight to b7 but
even now even with this move it's uh
difficult to defend after knight to d7
the position is impossible to hold
because there's one move that doesn't
come to mind immediately
but you guys will find it i have no
doubt about that uh once you pause the
video and find this incredible move that
wins the game for magnus while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
b pawn is actually unstoppable and pawn
to b5 uh wins the game this is what
magnus played so congratulations to
everyone who spots this and notice that
this would not be possible if the pawn
was not on b4 just just putting that out
there and now the the point is that if
the queen captures on b5 which is of
course what most of you are wondering i
imagine what happens now uh black just
blunders a knight that's the problem
knight before and the queen has no
squares to keep defending the the knight
on d7 is just uh
i mean
crazy you could play queen to d5 okay
this comes with check and also we force
a queen trade uh but i mean white will
just trade queens and then pick up the
knight so there that's no way to do it
so after knight to d4 there actually
isn't a good move for uh rajab here he
would have to play something but there
really isn't the move whatever you play
we're just going to capture the
the knight and we are up a piece so of
course completely winning so the b pawn
cannot be captured
tim removes the queen to d6 and now
magnus played queen to a6 and he was in
this position on move 36 that rajab
resigned again or rather well he didn't
lose in time but he resigned with four
seconds on the clock uh he still needs
to make four more moves uh to reach time
control but there just isn't a move to
make whatever you play here it's just
too easy to win this the pawn is
marching forward and it's a game over
and especially if you trade queens which
is uh kind of kind of a nice move for
example captures captures it's just too
easy to win this now it's an outside
pass pawn and there's no way to stop it
let's say knight c5 we put pressure on
the pawn block the bishop
knight e5 now we can even go after the
f7 pawn and after something like f6
we're gonna play knight to d7 now attack
the bishop attack the knight uh
there's no way uh white is just too
active and too powerful if knight
captures rook captures uh the pawn is
now coming to a7 and that's it let's say
rook 8 a7
and just the simple rook b7 the b8 wins
the game there's no way for black to
stop this let's say bishop somewhere
so really weird position we're going to
play this and after king moves let's say
this and it's still completely winning
of course if you capture we bring a
queen into the game and if you capture
on a7 we pick up the rook now we're up a
full rook and of course completely
winning
so uh
definitely an interesting game between
magnus and rajabov
in the style that they usually play uh
magnus uh very very precise and their
job also very precise and uh very
uh
uh very competitive uh you know just
giving up upon going for activity trying
to trying to push or being aggressive uh
but magnus just defended well and in the
end uh it was the pawn point the b4 to
b5 that won the game for white which
isn't uh odd i mean it's a past b pawn
what else do you expect uh so after
queen taste six uh rajab uh resigned and
uh the magnus gets his first classical
win uh in round three of the norway
chess 2022 uh so and that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it we're going to
cover some other games from round three
as there are very enjoyable games here
so stay tuned for that uh i would like
to wish uh wish a very happy birthday to
to drew as it is his birthday uh and i
would like to thank alexander john huart
valentin moreira and legend and varun uh
sudarsanan for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this uh
incredible event until it finishes uh so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
we're going to discuss the standings but
only after we check out a few more games
from round three see you soon